let me take a moment here and introduce
the panel and then a little bit about
what we're going to speak about as we
wrap the day here today and I and I
believe but excuse me I believe based
upon some of the pre discussion we had
here we'll have some energy injected
into discussion which you know as I look
across the day to day two we clearly had
that and i think there's benefit there
from the different points of view first
is Bill McNabb sitting to my left bill
was a chairman CEO of Vanguard probably
one of the most important points about
Bill though is he led every division in
mangar before he took this role so a
significant amount of background to step
in and obviously he manages an
organization that has over three
trillion dollars invested and he'll give
us in a moment his perspective on things
i've i've been with bill at different
times in different forms and heard the
comments he's made he's pushing some new
ideas into the marketplace and has had
some impact i think from doing that I'll
say no more about it because i'll leave
that to built to speak about that
patrick as you just heard I don't know
there's a university in the US you
haven't been a part of you know from
Harvard or Princeton a UC Berkeley
obviously here at Columbia overseas as
well in in Europe so he brings a an
international perspective to to what
we're talking about as well teal and
then Kurt shot who is the manning
director of cfa institute and he also
chairs the investment advisory board to
the sec he's been a front thinker in a
lot of the things he has
responsibilities and in cfa for for the
professional standards as well as the
government relations so he's very much
in in the front of what's going on in
the investing marketplace and some of
the changes that are taking place in in
the marketplace let me stop those
introductions for that and Bill why
don't you start us off with some
comments thanks Bill and let me just say
thank you to you and Ira and all your
colleagues here at the center
you know I think the work that goes on
here is incredibly important you know
when I sort of think about this work and
and and framing it and just you know
I've been here for the last couple of
panels and looking at the agenda earlier
you know what you're really talking
about is that the broader issue of how
capital gets allocated not just in this
country but around the world
increasingly and if you think about the
u.s. in particular you know capital
allocation through the markets through
the banking system we have probably the
best mix of any economy in the world and
I think it's actually been a really
important element to you know the
sustained growth of us over the last
hundred years and so I think getting
this right if you will is is really
really important so just a couple of
words of background as bill said we at
vanguard managed a little over three
trillion dollars which makes us the
largest mutual fund company in the world
and if you think about the mix if you
will roughly two trillion dollars in
equities of that about 1.7 is managed in
index funds and another 350 to 400
billion in active so we do both active
and indexed and I think the most
important point though rather than the
asset size there are really two
important points 1 it's who these assets
represent you know a lot of people in
the press to talk about you know
vanguards this Vanguard sway and
vanguards assets and so forth it's not
our money it's the investors money we
have 165 funds and if you think about
the people who are represented in those
funds it's you know everybody from
professors on college campuses to moms
and pops running little businesses to
large 401k plans but it's primarily
individual investors I think about 20
million of them or so are invested with
us and they're very long-term oriented
okay they're very long-term oriented if
you look at the turnover if you will of
our fund investors it's it's very low
and that means that they have long-term
perspective and I make that point
because it really does inform how we
think about governance obviously as a
index provider you
argue that were permanent shareholders
and that would be correct you know so
for 1.7 trillion dollars our holding
period is forever I think Warren Buffett
said that's his favorite holding period
we saw on the charge he's not quite as
forever as we are but if we're in index
if we hold the your equity you know the
security and our index fund we're going
to hold it forever and we have to be
able to effect if you will our
governance principles through persuasion
and influence as opposed to we don't
like what's going on in this particular
company will just sell it and I think
that has really shaped a lot of the way
we think about these issues you know
when it comes to governance and and
we've put a lot of work on that in this
regard over the last decade or so now 15
years ago we would publish our
guidelines on the website and let people
sort of read them and and and we'd vote
accordingly about half a dozen years ago
or so we began a much more direct
campaign to investors or to portfolio
companies i should say where we would
literally write the boards and say here
are principles here's what we think you
know you need to be focused on from for
the long run and what that's created
increasingly as a level of dialogue and
engagement i think we'll get to that in
some of the discussion but we've come to
think of this whole governance question
in sort of three broad categories
there's the quantitative so there's
certain basic principles that we believe
in very strongly it's not that there
aren't exceptions but you know one we
believe economic interests should be
reflected if you will by equity
ownership so that's no one share one
vote we believe the mid you know the
vast majority of boards should be
independent so again you can quantity
you can quantify that so that's the
quantifiable aspects you know on the
qualitative increasingly what we're
looking for there is assessing the
composition of the board and how that
mosaic if you will works in terms
helping the company achieve its
long-term goals now there's a really fun
example we had recently we were
approached by a consumer goods company
you would know the name they do mostly
toilet paper diapers things like that
and they were looking to add a new
director who was very technology savvy
I'm in fact I think the phrase that was
used he would be the digital director
and there was some back and forth in the
you know the little esoteric world
around governance about this and was
where they just check in a box or
following a fad we actually reached out
and had a long engagement with their
governance committee or governance and
nominating committee and what it turned
out that what they were really focused
on was the long-term success of the
company they believed was going to be
very dependent on a more significant
push into e-commerce and they had no one
on their board who really could speak to
that they'll add something I know you
could you could relate to so you know
that kind of engagement is really
important but and that's really the
third point so you think quantitative
you think qualitatively and then very
importantly we think about what we like
to describe is collaboration if you will
with the board where there's a real
active engagement between boards and the
investment community it's not just
management and the IR department anymore
but it's actually bored and and
investors when we get into the dialogue
i'll come back to some of what we're
seeing there but i think it's a very
positive trend i think it's a very
powerful trend and i think it's
something that really can contribute to
a better orientation toward the long run
as opposed to short-termism thank you
Bill so Curt let me let me jump to you
first you know with organizations like
Vanguard Blackrock state street and
others there's an enormous amount of
investment now concentrated
in some major funds when you step back
and take a look at that from your
perspective what's your perspective on
that desert warrior does it make you
feel good and then I think maybe a
follow on to that and i'm going to ask
both patrick and build a comment on your
comments then but as a follow on to that
that concentration has that enabled
activism in any way or not in any other
comments you want to make around that
question sir sure thank you very much
can you hear me okay my own good nice to
be here and and it's always great to
participate in the milstein centers
works I am particularly struck by the
title of this session the array of
shareholders because I have worked for
three very different kinds of
shareholders that we tend I think too
often to lump owners so if you look at
the corporate governance triangle and
you look at that corner where the
shareholders are we sort of say those
are owners and they're they're all the
same or they should be all the same I
work for a large public pension fund
thousands of proxies we voted we filed
shareholder proposals we did very active
engagement on the proxy voting itself I
worked for a large mutual fund company
same thousand proxies but a very
different approach to proxy voting it
was it was more of a it was more of an
afterthought it was not always very
considered and in many respects for the
portfolio managers it was a bit of a
distraction and finally I worked for an
active hedge fund here in Manhattan that
did the kinds of things that we've been
talking about today tried to file those
change proposals changing the board
changing the course of business and so
forth trying to unlock shareholder value
some of us out there think also known as
as a sort of quick buck artists but
they're very different 8,000 hedge funds
roughly 23 different mutual funds this
new advent of the exchange-traded
products in terms of the underlying
securities that are held area so there's
there's great concentration and on that
could our issue I guess I would just say
that net net from my perspective I'm not
sure that it's going to change very much
at all for three reasons first of all I
think that the sophistication of issuers
on proxy issues is is never been as
sophisticated as it is today the
propensity of those large concentrations
to actually vote with management most of
the time and then what I call the art of
the sway that is the what is the the
degree of difficulty in terms of
changing that perception so issuer
sophistication never been better you
look at the fortune 500 companies they
know how this game is played just like
shareholder activists you you focus on
the large investors that's where the
game is won and lost in the proxy
business and they are very sophisticated
that at that the officers the investor
relations people are very very
sophisticated and as IRA was talking
yesterday in our board meeting the board
of directors i think is much more
sophisticated about as well i think
there's still blind spots but the board
of directors knows that it has to be
seen as accountable to investors and
that it cannot be seen as as looking at
it at the investor population as the
enemy and i think they've done a
terrific job of trying to train change
that perception so that sophistication I
think breeds great great relationships
and great connectivity with the with the
big proxy voters secondly that
propensity to vote with management size
or no sighs and with all due respect to
Vanguard and a lot of the other
institutions that have great discipline
behind their proxy voting the fact of
the matter is that they vote with
management more times than not and
there's lots of studies out there about
this just like whether activism is good
or bad but if you look at one in
particular that the I see I did not long
ago 40 some of the biggest mutual funds
in the country and ninety percent of the
time they vote with management less than
half the time or half the time they vote
with with shareholders so there is a
great propensity to vote with management
and the sway right this way of voter
is I don't think any easier and what I
what we're hearing from a lot of the
activists that we talk it's not any
easier than it's ever been there's
certainly some really interesting new
develops you heard the media panel the
messages get out on both sides much more
quickly I think it's social media is
used extremely effectively to get the
message out maybe advantage and
activists in that sense because I think
they had more of a difficult time
getting their message out in the past
but this ability to be everybody to be
an author has allowed them to to get
that message out very quickly the
activists sway it's it's almost Trump
esque right there's some facts there's
some opinion and research based on what
they have for future forecasts of the
companies there's some nonsense but at
the end of the day it it sort of boils
down to the skill and the experience and
the credibility and certainly the
persistence of activists and as you
heard one of the other panels talk about
the level of sophistication of these
people in terms of how they communicate
the message has never been never been
greater that's not to say that activists
are hucksters or spend people but they
get the whole notion of the
communication and the importance of that
but that has not made the sway any
easier they just have employed new and I
think much more effective skills at that
so those three things those three
dynamics at least to me say that
management and issuers still have the
upper hand that they're still still the
winner and still champion in terms of
shareholder votes what a coma pill you
know I can't disagree with a high level
anything Kurt sight except that I would
say the vote thing is a little
misleading the ninety percent is an
accurate number but you know most votes
are very administrative in nature if you
go down and you actually look at the the
critical votes that either change
something that the numbers a little bit
different than that I would also say
that I don't think the vote is
necessarily the right thing to even look
at because i actually think one of the
one of the studies that i saw a couple
years about a year ago now that actually
reinforced this power of engagement that
we like to talk about is is looking at
structure of CEO comp and everybody
knows you know say-on-pay was sort of
the first big topic that people engaged
in and if you looked at the voting
record you'd say yeah it's very you know
it's ninety percent with management very
difficult to see that there's been any
progress but actually the progress is
really meaningful when you go through
the fortune 1000 companies and how CEO
compensation has been restructured
because of say-on-pay it actually
demonstrates that it wasn't just votes
that did it was there was actually a lot
of behind-the-scenes engagement that
actually were was able to change it now
we could still debate as to whether
enough has been done and so forth but
when you look at it structurally it's
much more aligned with longer term value
creation that it was you know say five
years ago so I guess I'm a little more
optimistic that thoughtful long-term
investors can have impact on how
companies are governed in a positive way
and you know it's interesting the
activists you know listening to all the
discussions around activism and I've
been part of some other panels you know
with you and others around this I
actually think it's kind of the wrong
topic because the activists just like
long only mutual fund managers or you
know traditional long-only pension
managers they cover a very wide spectrum
you have some investors who are by
nature very short-term oriented and that
really reinforces your point not all
owners are the same right you know some
have short-term orientation some have
long-term orientation you know the fun
data that that you showed you know was
incredibly powerful a lot of mutual fund
companies you know in the active side
they kind of rent the stock you know
they're there that you know they're
turning the stock over it's hard to make
the case that their long-term investors
so to me this comes down too much more
of a debate around the interests of
short term investors if you will versus
the interest of long-term investors I
happen to believe because of who we
represent that long term is really
really important and so at least for us
the case we're going to keep making the
case to management's and and and their
boards to think in terms of benefiting
those long-term investors recognizing
that not all their other owners are
going to be in the same in the same camp
patrick comets hear any comments with
respect to the dialogue here um I I
think Vanguard is is in a way a very
welcome development that with the
long-term outlook the what I worry about
you know in a way this why I brought up
these these numbers about Black Rock is
is the management team at Vanguard
sufficiently deep to be able to do the
due diligence do the long-term research
about all the companies that are in the
index and and to vote appropriately
that's an area where you know I I'm
waiting to hear more and and the other
point
I wanted to bring to the table that
related to what I was saying earlier we
shouldn't treat long-term investors and
shorter investors the same way long-term
investors bring a value to the company
they bring certainty they bring
stability they're valuable investors for
companies so my question is why
shouldn't long-term investors be
rewarded for that value that they're
bringing two companies okay let me pick
up on a comment you made when you were
making your comment skirt with respect
to funds institution who investors
tending to vote with management there
are big pension funds out there and in
some of the most recent activity we saw
one went one way the other went the
other way one of the things I've heard
at times from pension funds is they
really don't have the staff to do the
analysis of each of the voting things
that they need to do others may have
that I'd like to hear your comments on
those that are voting lots of shares in
lots of organizations what are they
using for their for their assessment are
they doing it themselves and what gives
a validity and if they're not doing it
themselves what gives the validity so
let me open it up to that really the
three of you thank you that's the that's
the the wonderful ISS question okay and
i know we have ISS lovers and haters in
the audience but I got to tell you this
I'm not based on my experience over the
years and you see the numbers that
Professor bolt and put up in terms of
what level of coverage these funds have
to have and it's almost impossible
nobody has 20 staff people like
Blackrock when you're talking 23
different mutual funds out there that
you know what is the level of resource
that they have a veil
for this so you rely on this advisory
service and I personally feel that ISS
combined with broadridge have brought
corporate governance and the proxy
voting process out of the dark ages
since I started in this business and I
remember walking in my very first day at
the public pension fund and and they
mentioned to me that I was also
responsible for the proxy voting and I
asked where were the proxies and they
took me to this office and the the
filing cabinet for the proxy statements
looked a lot like the garbage can and in
fact it was the garbage can and and
there was very little attention paid to
this because of the resource involved so
the advice is I think that service is
important I think there is on this
question of its validity I think it's
valid for the issuer if the issuer
degrees with it that's them that's the
bottom line and we have this same exact
dynamic in the CF the chartered
financial analyst realm where an analyst
will take a sell recommendation and and
God help the person that is a cell
recommender because it gets ugly and
they attack the person in terms of its
quality its correctness its accuracy and
and it's it's it's unfair and I thinks
but I think so i think the the analysis
is valid i think it's an opinion and I
think that shareholders are not all just
lemmings no the
you know I I think if you're an investor
you you actually have a responsibility
in this regard I think it's actually
part of the investment equation and so I
think when it comes to outsourcing that
you got to do so very carefully and you
know I would you know we've taken the
other side of a number of issues with
ISS or vessels you know pick any of them
and I don't think that's necessarily
pertinent but i do think if you're if
you're if you're an investor you
actually from you you have a
responsibility as to the governance you
know and we have this debate all the
time at the IC I as you might imagine
because we have large funds and small
funds and so forth but you know if
you're if you're a small fund provider
you know you you're a new startup or
whatever and you have half a billion
dollars a billion dollars under
management you have two funds you only
probably own 60 or 70 equities so you
know to me you should go do the homework
and you should know how you're voting
you know for the larger institutions who
are holding much you know greater arrays
of securities I actually do think and I
agree with you that it's because of the
ISS is and the glass Lewis's of the
world that this has come out of the dark
ages but I actually think it's now
thrust back upon you know large
investors in particular to actually
staff up and and have the appropriate
resources to be able to do the
governance the governance functions
properly and i think if you can't do
that you know it's a real i think it's a
real challenge to be an investor with a
comprehensive sort of from a
comprehensive fiduciary perspective
where do you come down that now I I
agree I agree there's the it's a
responsibility of the investors of
course ISS and last Louise it's helpful
information but it's the responsibility
of investors but again long-term
investors if they do
invest responsibly do their homework
vote responsibly they're providing a
costly service to the whole shareholder
base of a company and somehow this cos T
service has to be remunerated this is
why you have all the the mutual funds
that you've come across basically
playing lip service only all the you
know proxy proxy voting because they
don't have the resources they can't
afford to spend the money to do the to
do the research and therefore this has
to be compensated okay we're coming back
to dream so the point that is someone's
going to be doing the homework as a
long-term investor spend the resources
but how are they going to be compensated
for that for that public good so as we
started the day to day and a lot of the
panels and different panelists and
speakers have have used different terms
they've talked about engaged boards they
talked about a new governance principle
when I started this morning I used a
term activist board let me let me ask
each of you but maybe bill start with
you what what doesn't engage board look
like in your in your mind and when would
you be sitting what would you be saying
that that is a an engaged board and what
do you look for and and maybe a follow
on to that is what are signs that maybe
you don't have that yeah so you know I
think the the engagement issue is it's
if there's two dimensions to it there's
one that's the internal to the company
so I'm not going to talk to that you
know how you look at you different board
members contribution and so forth inside
but for us what an engaged word is an
investor looks like is somebody who has
actually a formal process for reaching
out to investors you know there's a
there's a story it's kind of becoming
lore inside Vanguard now several years
ago when we started having these
conversations about boards actually
engaging with shareholders we were at a
we were at a session much like this and
all of the directors in the room there
were a few CEOs in the room no no I
can't do that in our I can't we can't
have the boards actually talked to
shareholders and you know people threw
up reg FD they throw up all kinds of all
kinds of barriers and I had with me her
most successful active manager at
Vanguard the portfolio manager Vanguard
Health Care Fund she's a portfolio
manager managing partner wellington
management company and the largest
healthcare fun in the world really
successful great track record and she
she after she listened to all this she
said can I just say something as a
portfolio manager and her point was to
this gathered audience I don't really
want to hear from you what your strategy
is and so forth I get all that from your
management team and don't you want to
hear what I think about you don't you
want to so imagine that you're Eli
Lilly's board don't you want to know
what I think about your strategy versus
Pfizer's don't you want to know what I
think about it you know the Pfizer Wyeth
merger and how that's going to impact
you and she went through this whole
series of questions and everybody was
sort of stunned initially and they said
yeah absolutely that would be great and
then you know the flip side is of course
she would like to hear from them about
the biggest issues you know how are you
thinking about your management team and
CEO succession in particular how
confident are you about the long-term
strategy and all that so that's this
dialogue and you know it's interesting
the first time we had the conversation
was maybe four or five years ago and now
we're actually getting calls from many
of our portfolio companies from
independent lead directors independent
chairs
and sometimes a company with management
often not and they want to come in and
they want to talk and part of what they
want to do is actually I think of a
phrase you've used they want to actually
have an activist inside the boardroom
you know so they actually want to know
what's on the minds of big investors big
long-term shareholders and they want to
understand that so that if somebody with
a shorter term orientation comes around
and starts pushing on a lever the longer
term investor knows how to frame it and
you know it's not going to be perfect
there's there's art to this as well and
there's judgments involved but we're
finding that the level that level of
engagement is really really helpful
perfect what's an engaged board look
like to you I wouldn't speak with
experience okay and so I think I will
you know and I wish I could speak with
experience I think a couple things I
think it's the right mix of supporting
management I think it's a right mix of
being visionary and discouraging short
term behavior by management quarterly
earnings guidance it's a board that's
focused on the long-term value drivers
of the company and that it knows a
serious owner concern from a gadfly
owner concern and that they deal with
they deal with those issues and they're
seen as accountable to two owners I
think that's the I think that's the
right combination of engagement and
accountability okay we're getting close
to the end here Tom wise do week before
I've got several more questions but
maybe we have a question out here that
we can get out of Mike too
hi linden park from blackrock governance
team so it was kind of getting to feel
like it was an ad hominem that slide
about in a number of proposals but I
just want to focus on what mr. McNabb
was saying I think it's a little bit
misleading just look at all these
proposals as kind of a computer like a
bright line no heat though you know yeah
rather than looking at it as a bright
line number you have to see how many of
those are truly material contingent to
outcome from our engagement how many of
them are adjourned the meeting other
business administrative and I could
assure you from our perspective I do you
know our approach is very much aligned I
think with what mr. McNabb was saying is
that engagement truly drives it and I
think you know I want to focus the shift
the focus a little bit to kind of
looking at rather than looking at the
vote as a driving factor but you know as
an engagement based model something that
is really impelled by this iterative
conversation between long-term holders
and the company's that's what really
kind of can oversee how the companies
are creating long-term shoulder value
and in that sense you know we do a fair
amount of fundamental analysis in terms
of you know what's ROIC against wacc
when we're talking to companies
long-term strategies and you know you
can our record speaks for itself you
could look at the npx I personally draft
quarterly commentaries that are publicly
available on black rocks website about
our engagements and you know you asked
like what does they engage or look like
we have an idea because we talk to these
boards and we talked to directors who
failed their say on pay and we get a
lead director who's taking a black line
to the proxy and really getting to it
doesn't engage director and again I want
to just eat iterate rather than looking
at just kind of votes driving this kind
of a stewardship process that the
investors and companies are engaged then
I think the right way to look at it is
you know what is a catalyst here so when
we're looking at contentious situations
it's really we get involved even aside
from the vote related issues we know
three four five months before it gets to
a vote
these parties getting into the issues
with the p.m. so just wanted to kind of
set the record straight ok anybody won't
comment on dirt is there any other
comment yes back here get a mic over
here
hi thank you for being on the panel
appreciate all your comments I just
wanted to sort of react and then sort of
ask you all a quick question based on
kurt's last comment about paying
attention to real long-term shareholders
versus gadflies and I think there's
still some perception on the part of
some management's and boards about which
is which and sometimes even than the
institutional investor community that
large very diverse community about who's
really serious and drives governance and
then the folks who are doing very good
work i'm sure but not really driving
governance which would be vanguard is
taken seriously obviously Blackrock is
taken seriously by most corporate boards
and CEOs but that doesn't necessarily
hold true for say CalPERS CalSTRS new
york city new york state and other
public pension funds who to some are
gadflies because they're run by
politicians and unions are involved with
them so they're not really thought of as
serious and then if you go down from
there to state of Connecticut and others
in terms of just the size of their asset
basis so I just wanted to see if I could
get a little clarification from you all
about that thank you who wants to jump
in I think we should call Anne Simpson
and ask whether CalPERS is a gadfly well
I think I think I think issuers know
that I know they know Biggs they know
smalls they know active they know gadfly
and then they know serious influential
activists and they know when to pay
attention and and one when not to pay
attention and I think that's really
important for for a corporation from the
aw you know from the investor relations
department as i mentioned right up right
up to the board so i think they're I
think they're quite sophisticated on
that though if you want to comment
you know that I i I'd agree with kurt i
think that would be our experience as
well you know I think you always run in
this you know sort of the elephant in
the room and on these voting issues
always is what's sort of aligned with
quote unquote long-term shareholder
value if that's an important metric and
what's a political issue and which may
be a very important policy public policy
issue but how those get wrestled against
each other I think often is it is is
very difficult well listening hours
getting laid we have depth cause coming
up here to speak with isn't an era to
wrap up so I want to thank the panel for
the comments and discussion thank you
all